l'anti nature shadow qui est un peu
désordonné mais faut pas lui en vouloir
les shadoks en vérité le tenait
excessivement occupé quand un shadok par
exemple avait quelque chose qui le
gênait dans la tête
il allait à l'ordinateur névrose
biliaire calculs mentaux schizophrénie
dentaire aboulie verbales tout ça et
s'en occupait il répondait en général
par des traitements à base de nouilles
tranquillisants dans les cas graves ou
même aiguë il administrait des baffes
tranquillisantes et autres
manifestations au danic ce canton
chandhok qui n'avait rien qui les gênait
dans la tête il est quand il disait
quand même en leur faisant les lignes de
la main
il leur tirait les cartes et faisait des
horoscope du club est aussi de
démographie
ils partaient tous les matins dans les
campagnes pour compter les ai ramassé ce
que les shadoks pendant la nuit avait
cru bon de pondre entre au moment des
fêtes il descendait dans les foyers par
la cheminée et jouait de l'accordéon
avec tout ça il pouvait quand même le
temps entre eux pour tricoter et les
chaussettes un petit chat d'oc nécessite
raconté que c'était lui aussi qui
s'occupait des enterrements dans ces
pénibles pourront s'y connaît le nom
d'ordinateurs des pompes funèbres